- Like I said, I got the most all-purpose yards in
Super Bowl history or whatever, but
it don’t bother me because I won at home.
♪♪♪
- Comin’ in smooth!
- Chillin’ like a villain.
- Jacoby Jones, how you doin’?
- Man, I can’t complain, brotha.
- How’s retirement been treatin’ you?
- You know, livin’ this coachin’ life, man.
You know, I’m coachin’ at Lane College now.
- When was the last time you played pool?
- It don’t matter, it’s like ridin’ a bike.
- [Laughing] Let’s see what you got.
- I’m a bad man now.
Oooh.
- OK.
Jacoby, we talk about the playoffs.
You had a great playoff run in 2012
while you were a member with the Baltimore Ravens.
- Right.
- You become a legend with the Mile High Miracle.
The following week, y’all beat the Patriots.
Y’all are finally at the Super Bowl. And you’re home.
- I’m at home.
- You’re in New Orleans.
- The first thing I thought was, “I’m goin’ home.
I done played in that dome plenty of times.
I played in the All-Star—New Orleans All-Star Game in there.
Like, I’m—like, I’m—I was comfortable.
Like, I was—like, my mama cooked for the whole team.
As soon as we landed, we walked into the ballroom.
Food was right there, bam. Get you a plate.
- So you was cozy.
- Oh, I, I was at home chi—
I didn’t get no haircut!
- [Laughing]
- Like, I didn’t care! I didn’t care.
I walked in that thing like, “Man, I’m goin’ home.
Like, who am I to get fly for?”
- It don’t matter how you look.
- “I don’t care.”
I’m a bad man. Tryna tell ya.
I’m tryna tell ya!
- Take me through the beginning of that game.
- The first ball Joe threw me, I drop.
Instantly I got up and did like this, “My bad, Joe.
My bad.” Joe was like this—
[Whispering] My bad, my bad.
- [Laughing] “I got you!”
- “I got you, my bad!”
You end up scoring a touchdown.
Take me through what happened there.
Joe—I guess he had got pressured
or whatever when, when he threw it.
I’m like, “Oh, Lord, I gotta stop for it.”
So I just be like, “Catch the ball first.” Boom.
And I’m like, “Dude didn’t touch me.” I got up. I said, “Oooh.”
I looked at the pylon. I said, “I’m about to race him to the pylon.”
And when I seen my mans comin’, I said,
“You ain’t ‘bout to hit me, brotha!” He hit hard, too.
- Dashon Goldson.
- Boy, he hit hard.
- He a thumper. Flyin’ up on ya—
- I seen him. I’m like, “Boy, stop.”
- [Laughing]
- “You ain’t ‘bout to hit me.”
“Boy...child, please.”
And when Culliver ran back up, I’m like—
“I’mma holla at you. Track meet. Track meet.”
- But then you get to the end zone.
What, what was that move you hit?! You had—
- Oh, that’s, that’s all New Orleans!
- Go ‘head. What was that?
- It’s all New Orleans.
That’s what we used to do back in the G.
- OK.
- You know what I’m sayin’?
- And you hit the Beenie Weenie.
- [Laughing]
What was it like for you to do that at the Superdome?
- It’s so many athletes in New Orleans that don’t get a shot,
so I felt like I was showin’ them
anybody can make it out this city, you know what I mean?
- It was a dope moment.
And, and the Ravens were able to build up some momentum.
You go into halftime with the lead—Beyoncé’s performin'.
Are you paying attention to the coach,
or are you paying attention to Beyoncé?
- I was watchin’ Beyoncé.
- [Laughing]
- In the locker room, they got a monitor with Beyoncé playin’.
I’m sittin’ there lookin’ at Beyoncé.
You know, she—”uh oh, uh oh.” I was like, “Yeah!”
And all I hear: “Jacoby!”
“Sir? Yes, sir. I’m right here. I got it. Yep, I got it.”
- Comin’ outta that locker room, what happened?
- We come out there. I’m in my zone. I’m bouncin’.
I’m runnin’ off. Ray said, “Come here!”
I’m like, “What? Man, I’m in my zone.”
He come rub my chest. “Do what you do, man!”
- [Laughing]
- “What?! All right…”
He kicked it. I look, I said, “Ohhh, they done fucked up.”
[Clicking tongue] Took it down the pipe.
They put that play in, and I told ‘em, I said,
“Coach, if we call this play,
I don’t care how deep it is, you got to let me come out.
I asked Coach. He said, “OK, go ahead.”
I said, “It’s a track meet for me. It’s right down the pipe.”
[Clicking tongue] Down the pipe it was.
I start lookin’ at the Jumbotron. And I seen 2-6 behind me.
When I seen him ease up,
that’s when I looked to the sideline and said, “Watch this.”
So I gave ‘em the Ray Lew. I told him, “I’m gonna do it!”
You know what I’m sayin’?
- What did Ray say on the sideline after you hit that?
After you scored and you hit that?
- “I touched him! I touched him!”
- He wouldn’t stop talkin’ about
how much he touched your chest.
- “I touched him!” When he touched my chest,
I’m like, “Ray, whatchu doin’?”
- [Laughing]
- You touchin’ me for like that, man?
I’m in the zone right now, you know what I’m sayin’?
No, Ray, Ray, Ray my dog, though, man.
He, he’s a very inspirational person, man.
He, he know how to lead a—lead a troop.
After I ran it back, I’m on the sideline throwin’ up,
and they were like, “Jacoby, punt return, punt return.”
I’m like, “Hey, I’m comin’, I’m comin’.”
I look, next thing I knew, went [powering down noise].
The whole lights went out. On they side, not our side.
- Mhm.
- Born and raised from New Orleans.
Never in the history of America,
I never seen the lights go out in the Superdome.
Bro, the lights ain’t go out during
Katrina in the Superdome.
- [Laughing]
- Everybody stayed focused, though.
- Mhm.
- Right? A lot of 'em were stretching and doin’ all that,
but me and Torrey was playin’ freeze tag.
- Y’all were playin’ tag?
[Laughing]
- We were runnin’ around like kids, that’s what—
we was like big ol’ kids. Well, me and Torrey were.
- Once you come back from that third quarter,
then Kaepernick, the comeback,
they start makin’ this a game again.
What’s goin’ on through your mind
as you start seein’ that lead dwindle down to one possession?
- Goin’ through my mind?
“All my life I had to fight.”
Straight up, that’s all it is. We gonna, we gonna throw blows.
- So as the clocks turn triple zero,
you’re a Super Bowl champion.
Where are you going? What is going on through your mind?
- I just...fell to my knees, thanked God.
I then grabbed my son, I kissed him and...
I guess just was...a blessing, man.
- Joe Flacco won Super Bowl MVP.
- Mhm.
- In that Super Bowl. But you were ballin’ that game.
There’s a lot of people that thought you were the real MVP.
- It don’t—it still don’t bother me.
Like I said, I got the most all-purpose yards
and all that in Super Bowl history or whatever.
But it, it don’t bother me because I won at home.
How many people say they won a Super Bowl in their own city?
I’m good.
He coulda gave me the Corvette, though.
- [Laughing]
- You feel me?
- Flacco didn't need that Cor—
- He coulda gave me the Corvette, though, you feel me?
Could've gave me the ‘Vette.
- You coulda been ridin’ around the city in a Corvette.
- Yeah, he coulda gave me the Corvette,
man, so I—I bought my own.
- [Laughing]
- Naw, it’s—I, just winnin' at home was enough for me.
I’m gonna go and take my point.
- Yeah, go ahead, bro. Take your three points.
- You let me, bro.
- Take your three points.
- Free throw. Free throw.
Free throw.
Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R
to check out more dope videos like this one.